des feuillus et des résineux à perte de
vue paraît de ses couleurs automnales la
forêt de Vierzon cache le dépérissement
de ses essences il s'accentue avec les
sécheresses récurrentes et ce sont les
êtres qui payent le plus lourd tribu il
est vraisemblablement mort de sécheresse
ici c'est quasi certain ensuite le bois
qui se casse donc il tombe au sol et
c'est pas le cas de son voisin derrière
qui est resté bien vivant
de janvier à la mi-mai grosso modo on a
eu un énorme déficit hydrique qui a été
rattrapé au printemps ça a permis de
passer l'été ensuite à complété par
quelques orages on est toujours sur le
fil du rasoir et chaque été et pour nous
quelque chose d'inquiétant
on cherche des solutions on travaille à
ça ça nous occupe c'est même très
intéressant
mais j'ai des collègues qui sont
profondément perturbés par
les dépérissements forestiers
qui sont très très déstabilisés
finalement pour assurer l'avenir des
domaines les chercheurs et les
forestiers multiplient des
expérimentations de peuplement avec des
essences intermédiaires
on va pas chercher des chaînes qui sont
complètement dans le sud de la France
parce que en région Centre par exemple
nous avons encore des gelées
et les chaînes qui sont dans le sud de
la France
mettent en place leur feuille au
printemps beaucoup plus tôt que les
nôtres et donc s'il y a des gelés ils
vont être impactés par ces genoux donc
on va chercher des espèces qui ont
l'habitude d'avoir un degré de plus et
donc c'est un peu plus au sud du côté du
Poitou-Charentes par exemple dans la
forêt de Vierzon les sylviculteurs ont
installé un verger à graines de pain
rigida un arbre d'Amérique du Nord très
rare en France personne ne sait dire
comment il est arrivé jusque là mais
l'espèce s'avère plus résistante à la
sécheresse on va prélever des graines
qu'on va envoyer dans une sécherie de
l'ONF qui se trouve dans le Jura qui
traite ses graines pour ensuite les
mettre à disposition des pépiniéristes
qui vont produire des plans qui vont
être utilisés pour faire des plantations
tests dans les forêts publics et dans
les forêts privées parce qu'il y a aussi
une attente des forestiers privés sur le
pain rigida
dans les prochaines décennies les forêts
du centre Val de Loire devraient
ressembler à une mosaïque avec une
grande variété d'arbres une biodiversité
qui seule selon la vie des spécialistes
est en capacité d'assurer leur pérennité